INTERVIEWER: A
lone shopping cart
in the middle of a gravel
lot, its rusty wheels
bent inwards, sitting
without a purpose.
This picture shows a
relic of a different time.
Just kidding!
This picture shows a bunch of
crazy, oversized presidential
heads.
What's going on here?
The person who came across
this presidential head garden
is this woman.
JESSECA KEPPER: Hello.
My name is Jesseca Kepper, and
I'm an amateur photographer
from Atlanta, Georgia.
I have a special predilection
for roadside America.
I have been visiting these
kind of sites my whole life.
INTERVIEWER: The
sites Jesseca is
referring to are bizarre
American roadside attractions.
JESSECA KEPPER: I love
roadside attractions--
or roadside distractions,
as I like to call them.
I've been visiting them,
again, since I can remember,
but this one is
really a highlight
because of its obscurity.
INTERVIEWER: These seven foot
tall presidential busts-- 43
in all-- reside
in Texas and were
created by artist
David Adickes, who
specializes in oversize art.
JESSECA KEPPER: Apparently
he was inspired after a visit
to Mount Rushmore.
He said he was overwhelmed
when he saw the presidents,
and he hated that he
had to use binoculars
to see all the detail
work up on the mountain.
So on his drive
back to Texas, he
decided to create his own
presidential sculptures,
and he wanted his visitors to
be able to get as close as they
wanted to the pieces.
And sure enough,
when you're there,
you can get as
close as you want.
You can touch them.
You can climb on them.
INTERVIEWER: Jesseca's
travels have also brought her
to a giant pistachio, a giant
ball of twine, a giant clothes
pin, and of course, who
could forget the Idaho Potato
Museum-- each attraction
seemingly weirder
than the next.
But no matter where her
next road trip brings her,
no matter what big statue or
weirdly specialized museum
she visits, there's
a chance nothing
will ever top the
craziness of an empty Texas
lot filled with seven-foot
tall president heads.
JESSECA KEPPER: It was just
another piece of randomness
to add to the whole
goodness pile.
INTERVIEWER: "This
Happened Here"
aims to showcase compelling
photos and the stories
behind them.
If you liked this one, be sure
to check out this one next.
SUBJECT: I asked
someone to let me ride
doubles with her so I
can shoot action photos
of the girls riding in a pack.
INTERVIEWER: And as always,
thanks for watching.